tras ocho años ocupando el despacho oval
la etapa de barack obama como presidente
de los eeuu llega a su fin atrás queda
uno de los presidentes más carismáticos
y populares un presidente que llegó con
promesas de cambio y renovación incluso
prometió cambiar la relación de eeuu con
el resto del mundo de hecho desde la
época de jimmy carter- ningún presidente
estadounidense se había esforzado tanto
en distanciarse de su predecesor en lo
referido a política internacional
obama apostó por el multilateralismo por
reconocer el papel de china y por
terminar con el concepto de eeuu como
series del mundo
en este vídeo vamos a repasar los
principales puntos de la política
exterior obama así que empecemos
miran y el acuerdo nuclear
el acuerdo nuclear con irán alcanzado en
julio de 2015 tras dos años de intensas
negociaciones es sin lugar a dudas una
de las decisiones más controvertidas y
polémicas que ha tomado la
administración obama en política
exterior
tras heredar unas relaciones más que
tensas prácticamente en situación de
preguerra ante la posibilidad real de
que irán desarrollarse la bomba atómica
a lo largo de todas las legislaturas
obama ha utilizado la política del palo
y la zanahoria para presionar a la
teocracia iraní prueba de ello es que
mientras continuaban las negociaciones
el consejo de seguridad de la onu aprobó
en junio de 2010 la resolución 1.929 que
castigaba irán con duras sanciones
económicas por negarse a demostrar el
carácter no militar de su programa
nuclear la resolución prohíbe ir a
fabricar misiles balísticos que pueden
llevar armas atómicas e invertir dinero
en la extracción de uranio podemos decir
de forma sintética que el acuerdo
firmado con irán pone límites a su
programa nuclear a cambio de
levantamiento progresivo de sanciones
así
teherán se ha comprometido al no
desarrollar ni adquirir armas nucleares
a no producir uranio enriquecido durante
los próximos 15 años y a deshacerse del
98 por ciento de su materia nuclear en
la
levantó una gran calidad de críticas al
presidente obama tanto por parte del
partido republicano como por israel y
muchos de los países árabes si estás una
de esas raras veces donde la confluencia
de intereses entre israel y los países
árabes como arabia saudita les hace
dejar atrás su histórica confrontación
arabia saudí se alinea con los sionistas
en el acuerdo nuclear los críticos al
acuerdo afirman que teherán mantendrá su
capacidad para desarrollar la bomba y
que además el levantamiento de sanciones
inducir a un crecimiento económico en el
país que le otorgará al régimen iraní
ingentes recursos con los que
incrementar su influencia en la región
de hecho el propio presidente israel
benjamin netanyahu intervino en el corsa
de los eeuu para mostrar su oposición al
acuerdo y calificarlo como error
histórico
y asia y el pacífico habiendo pasado su
niñez y adolescencia entre hawai e
indonesia la identidad cultural de obama
está mucho más ligada al pacífico que al
atlántico algo que probablemente haya
influido de forma relevante en su
concepción del mundo y sus
planteamientos políticos porque sin
género de dudas si algo ha caracterizado
obama ha sido su determinación por
trasladar el eje de atención de la
política y los intereses estadounidenses
hacia el pacífico y no se trata
precisamente de un objetivo sencillo
china se ha convertido en toda una
potencia que aspira a tener una
influencia determinante en la región y
en el mundo
y todo se ha dicho obama ha sido
comprensivo con ellos y ha buscado
reconocer el papel chino en los foros
internacionales ahora bien las
diferencias son enormes y pekín ha
demostrado una creciente beligerancia
corea del norte- taiwán y las disputas
centrales con japón son espacios donde
de la política china choca frontalmente
con los intereses de eeuu ante esta
situación obama respondió con una rígida
voluntad de consolidar el papel de
estados unidos como nación y potencias
del pacífico
así bajo la administración obama eeuu ha
dirigido incrementar su presencia
militar en la región e incluyen el
despliegue de nuevas bases militares y
la presencia de más tropas permanentes
por ejemplo en australia concentrar en
el océano pacífico el 60 por ciento de
todos los recursos de la marina
estadounidense e impulsar la integración
comercial precisamente en esta línea se
firmó recientemente el que tal vez sea
uno de los mayores éxitos de obama el tp
o acuerdo transpacífico de cooperación
económica el mayor tratado de libre
comercio jamás firmado y que representa
ni más ni menos la acelera del 40 por
ciento el comercio mundial
rusia
aunque obama se planteó con objetivo de
recomponer la relación con rusia muy
deteriorada tras la de agresión rusa
georgia en la decisión de washington de
desplegar un escudo antimisiles en
europa oriental lo cierto es que la cosa
empezó con buen pie y en 2009 la propia
hillary clinton secretaria estado por
darle entonces anunció en moscú el deseo
de los eeuu de reiniciar sus relaciones
con rusia y superar pasados
malentendidos a partir de ese momento se
sucedieron importantes acuerdos como el
start suite que contemplaba una
importante reducción de los arsenales
nucleares de ambos países la
colaboración en el teatro afgano o el
apoyo de eeuu al ingreso de rusia en la
organización mundial del comercio el
séptimo exportador del planeta con 140
millones de habitantes que entró
oficialmente este miércoles en la ume ce
tras 18 largos años de negociaciones sin
embargo con el inicio del segundo
mandato de putin todo empezó a torcerse
y tras el maidán en ucrania la ocupación
de crimea y las consiguientes sanciones
a destacados líderes del gobierno de
putin las relaciones entre ambos países
saltaron por los aires y alcanzan hoy su
momento más tenso donde el regreso de un
estelar de guerra fría no es en absoluto
descabellado
y europa
precisamente y probablemente como
consecuencia del conflicto con rusia la
atención de obama a los asuntos europeos
ha ido de menos a más de hecho durante
estos años hemos visto cómo obama
decidían no acudir a la cumbre entre
eeuu y la unión europea de 2010 que por
tanto tuvo que cancelarse obama no
viajará a españa para asistir a la
cumbre unión europea eeuu reproches a
los países europeos por su falta de
compromiso a la hora de cumplir con el
gasto militar requerido por la otan y
criticar duramente la caótica sesión del
escenario de posguerra en libia un
conflicto en el que eeuu asumió un papel
secundario y que podemos decir ha sido
dada la desastrosa situación de libia
hoy uno de los grandes errores de la
casablanca en política exterior a pesar
de ello uno de los grandes objetivos que
se planteó obama en su segunda
legislatura que de momento tardará en
haber cumplido es el ctp el tratado de
libre comercio entre eeuu y la unión
europea del que haremos más adelante el
asunto no es si va haber o no comercio
la cuestión es en qué términos
el terrorismo y oriente medio
a tener que consumir muchas más energías
de las que tiene a periodistas en
oriente medio prácticamente ha cumplido
con sus compromisos de retirar las
tropas en irak y en afganistán contra el
consejo del pentágono por cierto y en
batín antiterrorista ha hecho un intenso
uso de los ataques selectivos mediante
el uso de cuerpos especiales y sobre
todo de drones de hecho podemos decir
también que obama el nobel de la paz
quien más misiles ha lanzado a la
historia cosas de la política el premio
nobel de la paz resultó ser el premio
nobel de los drones no este el mandato
de obama se han realizado más de
quinientas operaciones las que se
calcula se han eliminado a base de 3000
terroristas eso sí los daños colaterales
entre la población civil también ha
existido el avance logrado arroja luces
y sombras por un lado al qaeda ha
sufrido un gran retroceso y obama
incluso consiguió hacerse con la valiosa
pieza que era bin laden uno de sus
grandes éxitos sin duda pero por otro
lado muchos culpan a su estrategia del
crecimiento del estado islámico en la
zona y el fracaso de las llamadas
primaveras árabes
hay ser el estado islámico está
homenajeando el presidente obama es el
fundador del país
respecto a siria digamos que ha sido un
conflicto en el que no ha querido
enredarse y en cuanto a israel con quien
ha mantenido unas tensas relaciones se
despide con un acuerdo de asistencia
militar récord en sus importes en fin
por el camino se quedan un montón de
iniciativas históricas como la visita a
la habana el impulso de la lucha contra
el cambio climático donde obama ha
conseguido grandes éxitos en su agenda
como por ejemplo la asunción de
responsabilidad por parte de china sin
duda obama ha sido un presidente cuya
política exterior ha sido controvertida
y en general no ha gustado ni a la
izquierda ni a la derecha será esa una
prueba de son basura sólo el tiempo lo
dirá personalmente no soy el mayor fan
de barak ni mucho menos pero hay que
reconocer que la administración obama ha
expandido el comercio ha sabido orientar
a los eeuu a la zona del mundo que más
está creciendo y más se está
desarrollando y ha dejado atrás la
filosofía de la guerra como solución a
todo conflicto bueno vosotros qué
pensáis marcará un antes y un después la
gestión de barack obama en los estados
unidos y de ser así será para bien o
para mal espero vuestros comentarios si
está roto antes ante el vídeo desde el
like i suscribiros al canal si aún no lo
habéis hecho ya y por supuesto no se
olvide
de seguirnos en facebook y twitter hasta
la próxima